descent were tragically killed by a
gunman who attacked three asian-run
businesses in the aftermath of that
horrific attack the president and vice
president traveled to atlanta to meet
with leaders of the asian american
community and hear about pain the pain
and fear that too many asian americans
have felt since the beginning of the
covet 19 pandemic today erica moritz
mortugu deputy assistant to the
president and aapi senior liaison is in
atlanta representing the white house as
the community mourns the victims of this
awful tragedy ambassador katherine ty
our u.s trade representatives and
co-chair of the white house initiative
on asian americans native hawaiians and
pacific islanders also spoke at a vigil
in michigan to stand against asian amer
anti-asian hate past and present on this
somber day our administration remains
fully committed to reducing the gun
violence that terrorism terrorizes our
communities and to advancing safety
inclusion and belonging for all asian
americans native hawaiians and pacific
islanders i wanted to
make a note on gas prices
right now oil prices are 94 per barrel
when oil was at this level one month ago
the average cost of a gallon of gasoline
was three dollars and 49 cents and yet
now the average cost of gas is four
dollars and 32 cents when it comes to
oil and gas prices many accept the gas
prices rise quickly but fall slowly the
so-called rockets and feathers
phenomenon but president biden rejects
that americans deserve relief and fast
as oil prices fall retail gasoline
prices are updated at least daily and if
gas retailers costs are going down they
need to immediately pass those savings
on to consumers so i will reiterate what
the president said to oil and gas
companies last week the invasion of
ukraine and the volatility of the oil
market is no excuse for excessive price
increases profit padding or any effort
to exploit american consumers no one
should capitalize on putin's aggression
by taking advantage of american families
and this chart which you see here shows
both the price of crude oil and you see
where where it is as it relates to the
price of gasoline and as you've seen it
gone that go down the price of gasoline
obviously has not gone down so that is
the explanation of that particular chart
also just wanted to note before we get
to questions
that
in some good news
we saw a history made yesterday with the
strong bipartisan confirmation of
shalonda young the first black woman to
serve as the director of the office of
management and budget for the past year
she served as a key advisor to the
president member of the economic team
she's led the development of the
president's budget and helped
effectively implement his agenda and
vision across the entire federal
government she's not just making history
she's exceptionally qualified in his
vast budget experience from her years
leading staff on the house
appropriations committee so we're
thrilled to have her as our confirmed
director finally i know you just heard
the president give remarks on this but
for clarity's sake and to make sure
everybody fully understands the totality
of assistance what the president
announced today was an additional 800
million dollars in security assistance
to ukraine bringing the total u.s
security assistance committed to ukraine
to 1 billion
in just the past week and more than two
billion dollars since the start of the
biden administration and more
specifically since last march there's
additional security assistance in the
omnibus the president uh signed into law
yesterday but we're also working with
ukrainians and others on delivery
mechanisms of that so what he outlined
today is the additional 800 billion from
that and this assistance as you heard
him say will take the form of direct
transfers of equipment from the
department of defense to the ukrainian
military to help them defend their
country against russia's
unprovoked and unjustified invasion it
also includes u.s produced short-range
air defense systems the ukrainians have
been using to great effect uh systems
they are trained on we've also
identified and are helping ukrainians
acquire additional longer-range systems
on which their forces again are already
trained as well as additional munitions
for these systems and we will continue
to work with allies and partners to
transfer equipment to ukraine at least
30 countries to date have provided
security assistance to ukraine since the
invasion began and in 2022 the
department of state authorized
third-party transfers of defensive
equipment from more than 14 countries a
number that continues to grow as allies
and partners and create support to
ukraine chris why don't you kick us off
all right uh first off just going to
note this is your 200th briefing oh wow
time flies when you're having fun and we
will celebrate with a lot of questions
okay 200 let's do it
the white house said the russian actions
in ukraine are under close scrutiny
potential war crimes uh but today
president biden directly labeled putin a
quote war criminal had something changed
administration's assessment uh what
brought this new remark from the
president today i think the president
was the president's remarks speak for
themselves he was speaking from his
heart and speaking from what he's seen
on television which is barbaric actions
by a brutal dictator uh through his
invasion of a foreign country there is a
legal process that continues to is
underway continues to be underway at the
state department uh that's a process
that that they would have any updates on
so another question the military
assistance
uh is the white house as the
administration facilitated transfer of s
300 uh anti-air missiles
houses facilitating that how many might
be provided to ukraine well let me just
provide to you um as i've educated
myself a little bit on weapon systems
over the past few days i thought this
might be helpful to you so s 300s are
anti-aircraft
uh systems we are providing stingers or
also anti-aircraft systems there are a
range of anti-aircraft systems that
different countries have around the
world so as i noted i know that uh
president zielinski called out
specifically s 300s and while i'm not
going to get into specifics for security
reasons we are continuing to work with
our allies and key partners to surge new
assistants including soviet or russian
origin anti-aircraft systems which is
exactly what that is but what we're
talking about here is how to provide
them a range of anti-aircraft systems
that will help them do exactly what
they've been doing which is to shoot
down planes and part of what the
president announced today was additional
stingers that serve exactly that purpose
given that yes
much longer longer range than the
stingers is that part of the
administration's plan to find a way to
facilitate that
without getting into specific systems
there are a range of anti-aircraft
systems that do have longer range we are
continuing to consult with our allies
and keep partners to surge that
assistance but i'm not going to get into
more specifics the last question is uh
the federal reserve raised rates today
helped by inflate camp inflation
administration confident that the fed
can beat inflation through rate hikes
and not risk a recession
well i would note that chairman powell
spoke to exactly that question today so
i would point you to his specific
comments answering that question where
he did express confidence in the ability
to take the steps he announced and avoid
that i would note that while they we
respect the independence of the federal
reserve as you of course
as we have said many times
the president has also said in the past
that he recognizes uh not only their
independence but that it is appropriate
and necessary for the federal reserve to
recalibrate
recalibrate their that their support to
maintain stable prices and obviously
they made an announcement today
as it relates to we obviously closely
watch um hear from the administration
and closely monitor all risks and we
continue to believe that the united
states economy is positioned well to
deal with the challenges ahead even as
we continue to monitor and obviously
there are events that impact the economy
including an invasion of a foreign
country um and we're seeing that impact
as well play out in the economic data
go ahead back on this question of
labeling putin a war criminal i mean
this war has now been going on for three
weeks so far the president has declined
to use this label as you know there is
an ongoing sort of formal process before
you can use this term so something must
have changed for the president to feel
like he can take this additional step
today what what else the president was
answering a direct question that was
asked and uh responding to what uh he
has seen on television we have all seen
uh barbaric acts horrific acts by a
foreign dictator
in a country that is threatening and
taking the lives of civilians impacting
hospitals women who are pregnant
journalists others and i think he was
answering a direct question
the administration is making it very
clear and publicly how much assistance
the u.s is providing to ukraine uh
whether we are fighting in this war or
not the us is obviously heavily involved
putin certainly knows knows all of this
he knows where this equipment is coming
from is there any concern that you run
the risk that he may view this as the
kind of direct us involvement the direct
confrontation that you are trying to
avoid well all the equipment that we're
providing whether it's stingers or
javelins or counter-artillery uh counter
uh mortar radar uh counter ua track uav
tracking radars anti-armor systems
unmanned aerial systems this is all
defensive equipment and materials it is
more than we've ever provided to ukraine
in the past it is a significant amount
of assistance that we have expedited the
delivery on and we will continue to do
exactly that but as our department of
defense and they can certainly speak to
themselves they do for themselves they
do risk assessments they assess what the
impact will be of the types of
assistance they're providing we're
obviously watching how the types of
assistance we have provided have helped
the ukrainians courageously and bravely
fight back and we're giving them more of
that assistance we've also given them
additional types of assistance we had
not yet provided to them but again these
are all defensive weapons systems
you have noted from the podium that
putin has shown no signs of changing
course you've also noted that there are
significant consequences that putin
could still face even with this
additional aid that you're providing
today it seems there are still other
options on the table so why roll back
why not use every tool at your disposal
now to spare additional lives well i
think if you look at the range of tools
that we've used to date we have
we have implemented more economic
sanctions uh than we have on any other
economy in the world you could compare
it potentially to iran or maybe north
korea but russia is a much more
significant economy a larger economy and
so i wouldn't say that we are holding
back in that sense we do have additional
steps we can take as we've talked about
a bit in here before obviously the swift
uh banking system and the implementation
of those sanctions happens institution
by institution uh there are additional
individuals that can be sanctioned uh we
can have new targets we can think deep
in the severity of sanctions on existing
targets we can further eject russia from
international economic or the
international economic order we can
further deny russia the capacity to
modernize and diversify its economy like
we have with the export controls and the
and the cutting off of access to a lot
of technology and we can further and uh
expose and hold to account the
kleptocracy these are additional actions
we have additional options we have
and we can take them and that is a
decision that we would make through a
discussion internally but what are you
waiting for
we're we have additional escalatory
steps that we can take but i would just
note that we have not held back we have
done more economic sanctions and had
more uh put in place more financial
consequences than we have in any uh
circumstance ever in the world so i
wouldn't say that is holding back in any
capacity
does the white house have any insight or
assessment of the negotiations between
ukraine and russia president zielinski
seemed to indicate there'd been some
progress but president putin's remarks
later did not make the same impression
we obviously stay very in very close
touch with the ukrainians but what i
would note is we haven't seen
any effort to de-escalate from president
putin and from the russian military so
while we will continue to be very
supportive in a range of ways of
diplomatic efforts whether that is
engaging directly with uh with the
ukrainians with the europeans you saw
obviously jake sullivan had a call with
his counterpart this morning as well uh
but we also are providing a range of
security assistance and economic systems
to make sure we're strengthening ukraine
as they go into these discussions but
it's hard to have a hard-to-have
negotiations that are going to be
effective if uh if uh you know one party
is continuing to escalate president
zolinski and his remarks in congress
today again made his request for a
no-fly zone
he no doubt is aware of president
biden's position on that
is there any scenario in which president
biden would change his mind
well first let me say that
the president watched the speech i know
some of you asked this so let me just do
this now he watched the speech from his
residence in his private library as you
heard him say he thought that president
zielinski was passionate was powerful
and certainly he and he watched the
totality of it uh we are in very close
touch with ukrainians nothing that he
asked for or said today was a surprise
in that sense um and if we were
president zielinski uh we would be
asking for everything possible as well
and continuing to ask for it because he
is watching uh his country and his
people uh be attacked and brutalized by
president putin and the russian military
but how president biden makes decisions
is through the prism of our own national
security and and as we've said before a
no-fly zone would require implementation
it would require us uh potentially
shooting down russian planes nato
shooting down russian planes
and we are not interested in getting
into world war iii just lastly is does
the white house view russia
being ready to go back and allow the
iran nuclear deal to move forward well
we can't blissfully speak for russia i'm
sanctioned they especially wouldn't let
me speak for them i guess now i don't
know if it's changed but um but i would
say that russia does not want iran to
acquire a nuclear weapon uh we don't
either while we have a range of strong
disagreements with them uh we can we
can't speak for their intentions here
certainly we believe it's in both of our
interests for this to move forward go
ahead jen does the president believe
that it would be important for president
celenski to be at the nato senate next
week as long as it is safe for him to do
so
i have not discussed that exactly with
the president uh the president's going
there to meet with nato partners and
allies obviously president zielinski is
uh
his country is in the middle of a war uh
so i have not talked to him about that
specifically um i wanted to ask you
about jake sullivan speaking with his
russian counterpart um the russian
readout said that this happened at the
us's initiative and the nf the nfc's
readout said that if russia is serious
about diplomacy then moscow should stop
attacking ukraine you've obviously
consistently said from the podium that
the door to diplomacy is never closed
are we seeing though a ramp up in
diplomatic efforts with russia right now
well this is the most senior
conversation between the u.s and russian
officials since uh secretary blinken
last spoke with foreign minister lavrov
i would note that we have maintained
direct and indirect contact with the
russians through our embassy and
officials there and best including
through ambassador sullivan and we also
have a military deconfliction channel uh
but we requested this call to clearly
lay out our commitment to continuing to
impose costs on russia if they do not
stop attacking ukrainian cities and
towns and to warn them about the
consequences and implications of russia
potentially using chemical or biological
weapons in ukraine so it's important to
convey those um those consequences
directly this is an opportunity to do
that
just one final question on a different
topic the administration has marked the
one-year anniversary of the atlanta spa
shootings
and spoken about some of the actions
that the federal government has tried to
take as you know this week of an asian
woman in new york 67 seven-year-old
woman was hit more than 125 times was
stomped on was called the racial slur
obviously that video is very sickening
to watch do you know whether the
president has seen that video and just
what would the president's message be to
anyone in the asian american community
who feels like well the actions that the
government is taking are not enough to
stop these attacks and they say that
they feel afraid well i would say that
um our message to them i have not talked
to the president about this specific
video i have seen it a number of us have
seen it and as you said it is very
difficult to watch um i would say that
his message to them would be um our work
is not done uh that we want to stand by
your side and continue to stand up for
you to protect you to call out uh this
type of discrimination and um and uh
horrific actions as is as including in
the example you gave um and that what he
has done is tried to elevate uh this uh
type of um anti-asian um hate in this
country so that people are aware of it
so that communities across the country
can continue in that fight as well but
the work clearly is not done and we need
to uh be steadfast in it go ahead
a
david
questions on uh today's event so first
the conversation that jake sullivan had
with his
russian counterpart he issued a very
specific warning about chemical and bio
there was no mention in the readout of
nuclear which is obviously a concern for
battlefield weapons was that a
deliberate omission has that
conversation taken place in a different
channel
i'm happy to go back to them and see if
there's more we want to read out from
the conversation i think uh what the
most important component here uh to take
away i hope is that we wanted to have a
direct conversation about what the
consequences would be a further
escalatory action but i don't have more
to read out at this point in time and
then um on your answer just before about
your um concern
about the mig planes we went through a
little bit of this yesterday um i think
you just said that you didn't want to
have nato pilots bringing down russian
planes
but under the administration's policy of
moving out this long-range anti-aircraft
it's okay to have nato equipment
bringing down russian planes
as long as it's launched by ukrainian am
i understanding the policy right well i
think you've heard us talk a fair amount
about the poland the planes from poland
and again poland is a sovereign country
so they can make decisions on their own
what we have done is done an assessment
of our role in the u.s role and what our
uh view would be of nato of this these
planes taking off from nato airspace
again i would note that the equipment
that we've provided is defensive as you
know not offensive and we see that as
being a difference we're also looking at
planes can be used for an offensive
purpose and the the
anti-missile systems correct also uh
also i would note that what our
department of defense officials also
assessed is what's most effective and
well the ukrainians still have squadrons
of planes to utilize as i think any
military official could confirm for you
uh the types of assistance that we are
providing today including stingers and
other assistants that we're amping up
support for is exactly what we feel is
effective in fighting this war
go ahead thanks jen today in putin's
speech he implied that there's going to
be even greater crackdowns on civil
liberties inside of russia is there
anything that you all believe that you
can do in terms of sanctions or
supporting um the opposition there out
that you all are not already taking
well we look at all of the actions that
president putin does and we assess uh
what responses we may have i have
nothing to predict at this point in time
but obviously as he has taken actions uh
we have taken actions in response
specifically on um the case of alexander
navalny he prosecutors there just said
that they want to sentence him for a
13-year president which is why that's a
response to that i think we've spoken a
number of times in the past about the
courage of alexi navalny
about the role he's played
in being an outspoken advocate for
freedoms in a country that has been void
of them and i would echo those that
response now go ahead thanks jim can you
talk a little bit about what president
biden specifically hopes to accomplish
in his trip next year beyond shoring up
nato allies
well that's a big part of it that's a
very important part ashley shoring up
nato allies look i think from the
beginning uh and even before
this conflict uh began
we have viewed um rebuilding alliances
in the world um as a key component of
what the biden administration president
biden could specifically do on the
global stage following uh his
predecessors uh his predecessor's
actions so uh what he'll be doing he's
while he's there he's meeting with our
nato allies to coordinate our deterrence
and defense so they will obviously talk
about where things are on the ground uh
coordinated responses assistance we're
providing uh nato at this point as you
all know is more united and more
determined than we've been in decades so
we certainly would would be focused on
continuing that uh unity um he would
also
he's also going to join uh european
leaders um in a separate part of the day
to discuss our work to impose economic
costs on russia as i noted earlier there
are obviously a range of coordinated
steps and costs we've taken
there's more that we could do we have we
have the capacity the ability to do and
we want to continue to do as much of
that in a coordinated fashion we're also
looking to continue to provide a range
of humanitarian support especially as
we're seeing a surge of refugees uh
continue to grow across the border
and uh you know discuss a range of ways
we can address the challenges stemmed
from putin's war
in a coordinated fashion on a slightly
lighter note does the administration
have a position on the effort in
congress to make daylight savings time
permanent
i have seen those reports i was trying
to think of a joke i couldn't think of
one um i don't have a specific we are
obviously coordinated and work closely
with congress on all uh legislation they
consider but i don't have a specific
position from the administration at this
point is it more of a morning person or
an afternoon because people are often
divided in those weights so i'm just
curious that is true now uh to de-link
it from the specific question he is more
of an evening person but i don't know
what analysis you'll provide but i'll
look forward to reading tomorrow go
ahead thank you jen um has president
vladimir spoken to president zolensky
today uh not since this morning um
if he does and when he does which i'm
sure he will soon we will provide that
readout to all of you got it thanks um
today president zolensky made a
distinction between a humanitarian
no-fly zone and a blanket no fly zone
does the administration view them as
being different for the same thing
well there have been descriptions of
both of those over the past couple of
weeks and sometimes a humanitarian and i
don't want to put words in his mouth but
a humanitarian no-fly zone can be
specific geography or a portion of
western or parts of ukraine whereas a
no-fly zone sometimes people refer to it
as the totality of the country uh in our
view and the view of the military
there's not a difference in terms of the
implementation and the escalatory impact
thank you
and then today the vice president spoke
with the president of slovakia which is
one of three countries that can provide
those s-300s but the readout does not
mention the missile system so can you
tell us whether the vice president
directly asked slovakia to provide them
to ukraine
i can't get into more specifics other
than to convey that we are uh having
conversations with a range of allies
about providing
additional
assistance um
anti-aircraft assistance and again there
are a range of of systems including some
of the systems that we provided and we
are going to be expediting delivery of
to ukraine from the united states and
one more on um the warplanes that
zielinski asked for today i mean you've
made very clear that the us
is opposed to doing that right now i
wonder if the us is also discouraging
other nato allies from providing
fighter jets even if the u.s would not
have to serve as a middleman if other
countries can make their own sovereign
decisions
and then one more on the asian
hate crimes because you mentioned them
at the top too um do you know if the doj
has concluded that there is not enough
evidence um to charge the shooter in
atlanta with a federal hate crime i
couldn't speak to that from here you'd
have to ask doj that question and then
more broadly um since the administration
adopted new policies that are meant to
make it easier
to identify these crimes as hate crimes
do you can you point to any progress
again i appointed the department of
justice who were implementing thank you
sure good job thank you chad um
just one more and a lot of people have
asked about the the mix but can you
lay out for us why the administration
sees
migs as provocative
and javelins and stingers is not
provocative well first javelins and
stingers are defensive weapons
uh migs or planes are offensive weapons
which are a different type of military
system i would say the other assessment
that we've done not through here not
through the white house not through the
president from from the department of
defense is to assess what is effective
and what works uh in terms of fighting
this war on the ground and that is why
we provided an additional uh one billion
dollars 800 million announced today but
1 billion this week of assistance
utilizing a number of the
high-level military systems stingers
javelins counter-artillery
counter-mortar radar anti-armor systems
that we know have been effective and we
know the ukrainians are trained on
third ukraine's air force already has
several squadrons of mission capable
aircraft and giving them more would not
significantly change their effectiveness
and finally i touched on this in the
beginning offensive versus defensive but
we also
do risk assessments from the department
of defense about what would be
escalatory um and what and that is
obviously uh what we would like to avoid
john kirby has said that success for the
u.s mission in ukraine is a free
independent sovereign ukraine we've also
heard that the official mission is to
prevent uh escalation
uh beyond
ukraine
which is it
both are true if we're not specific
about
what exactly
the
desired outcome is how do we expect
people i could why could both not be
true a sovereign ukraine and preventing
them from expanding beyond
and then um moving on to
the
nuclear deal general mckenzie told the
armed services committee that from
everything that he can see
the irgc is a terrorist organization is
the white house willing to de-list the
irgc from the foreign terrorist
organization list in order to get a deal
with iran
we're still in the negotiations so i'm
not going to speculate or outline from
here what the final details look like
and these are likely
the group responsible for firing
missiles us facilities in iraq so as
long as americans aren't killed are
there are there no consequences for
something like that all in an effort to
get a nuclear deal again you're
speculating on something that is not
even finalized the deal is not finalized
what i would note and i would just go
back to why we're negotiating this deal
and right now we're negotiating this
deal because
iran's nuclear gains are threatening u.s
interests there's urgency to taking
steps to contain that which is why we've
been engaged so closely and that is all
the result of president trump pulling
out of the deal and iran moving closer
to having the capacity and acquiring a
nuclear weapon and speeding up their
breakout time so we are here thanks to
the actions of the last president and
the last administration and it is in our
interest it is in the global interest to
prevent iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon go ahead kristen thanks jen how
quickly can ukraine expect to receive
the list of military aid that president
biden laid out today well we have
expedited as you as you would as we've
noted from here about 300 million
dollars worth of military and security
assistance over the last couple of weeks
we continue to have channels to deliver
military assistance and so we would
continue to work to deliver it quickly
uh there have been military deliveries
even in the last few days so it has been
rolling and you're confident it will
continue to be including these new we
continue to have channels to do exactly
that yes
and the president said going back to
long-range air defense systems he was
working with allies to acquire them
can you tell us where they are what the
expectation is in terms of the timeline
for getting those systems
i can't outline where they are because
we're going to keep those conversations
private i would note that a great deal
of what we're doing is augmenting the
type of effective military assistance
that we're doing from the united states
and uh working to prioritize equipment
that they are trained on but we are
discussing with a range of partners when
we say stinger or javelins those are
brands there are different kinds of
similar assistants or other types of
assistance that different allies have
around the world and i want to go back
to the mix quickly and just be crystal
clear about what you're saying because
when i asked the president about this
earlier said he's not going to comment
he didn't say that it's not an option so
well we've spoken to it yeah
approximately 167 times so maybe
well here's 168. go ahead go ahead
there's a growing number of republicans
and democrats
who are supporting the us striking a
deal with poland to said in the mix you
have uh elise stefanik earlier today
saying uh ukraine needs those migs you
have uh scalise say getting those migs
in immediately is critical there's a
growing course of voices saying that now
is the time
has the president reconsider his fans at
all at this point no because our
military makes assessments uh which they
put out that assessment last week and i
would just echo that one part of the
assessment
is based on what equipment is effective
in fighting this war anti-armor and air
defense systems they are effectively
defending the country that is what we
have provided additional assistance on
second they have several squash
squadrons of mission capable aircraft i
don't think that's enough you heard
presidents that are not being christened
that are not christian that are not
being utilized this is the assessment by
our defense department
third
they are also assessing uh that the
transfer to ukraine may be mistaken as
escalatory so this is how our defense
department is assessing they are
assessing also that it would not
significantly change the effectiveness
of the ukrainian air force and these are
the types of risk risk assessments we
certainly understand we share the
passion the anger the horror and what
we're seeing and that is why we are
we significantly increased the types of
military assistance the types of
equipment that we know is effective and
our defense department has determined is
effective in fighting this war president
valencia ended his speech today by
saying being the leader of the world
means to be the leader of peace is
president biden is satisfied that he's
needing this leadership moment given
that we're now three weeks into this
war well i would say that president
zelinski also thanked the president uh
for the role he's played and uh without
president biden there would not be 30
countries around the world providing
security and military assistance nato
would not be as alliance as it is
we would not be unified in our
implementation of the most crippling
sanctions we've ever implemented against
a foreign country
we will continue to stand by uh
president zielinski's side the side of
the ukrainians and in the brave and
courageous ukrainian people and continue
to build on the efforts that have been
underway today we're very quickly in the
wake of the second gentleman testing
positive has president been tested today
and has a vice president
um uh i can check on the vice president
the president has not been he was tested
on sunday he was not a close contact so
we have not changed our testing
mechanism let me check on the vice
president i know they put out some
information last night i'll see if
there's an update go ahead thanks jen um
can you confirm that switchblade drones
were part of the the package and if so
do you consider that still defensive
uh i don't have more details beyond what
was in our fax sheet to confirm from
here okay and um is the us monitoring
the hostage situation and uh in
chernobyl and um did that come up in the
call with sullivan today uh we are
definitely closely monitoring that uh
situation um and i can check and see if
that was a topic of discussion during
their call also just uh lastly here um
what does the administration make of the
russian proposal of ukraine being
a demilitarized austrian swedish type
model
as a part of their 15 point discussion
look our focus is on supporting the
ukrainians
in their efforts obviously pursuing
diplomacy is something we'll always
support but as president putin and the
russian military continues to take
escalatory steps on the ground
and take military action against
civilians and innocent people uh we
think that is the biggest place where we
need to stay exchanged go ahead and ask
if you're in your position today to say
anything more about the contours of the
president's travel next week
what's after brussels
i don't have anything more for you at
this point in time we're still
finalizing the additional any additional
details
the fact that the second gentleman did
test positive does that raise concerns
here about the state of
the situation in the country with va ii
or any other variant that might be
around
it does not not from our health
officials
i'll go back and second questions
yesterday i wonder if you can speak to
that in particular will you name
the president
soon for that post he certainly will
nominate a new person to serve to
nominate to that post it's been less
than a day so it may be a little bit
more time
we are certainly disappointed
sarah blumraskin remains one of the most
highly qualified people to ever be
nominated to this position but it's an
important role and he will nominate
someone to fill the position
was there an attempt to get bipartisan
support or was said her statement sort
of seen as the
decisive one
i would say as i said from this podium
um if there was continued efforts to
seek bipartisan support and continue to
support her candidacy
is your position that the drones were
assessed by the
defense department to not be perceived
as escalatory and to not be perceived as
offensive weapons again i don't have
anything more to confirm beyond what's
in the fact sheet and specifics in there
but defensive weapons is what we have
provided go ahead yeah um i'll go back
in a second the administration uh
including you yesterday have raised very
dire warnings about what will happen if
this coveted money doesn't come through
president biden held a bill signing
yesterday a very celebratory bill
signing for a piece of legislation that
that was stripped out of that funding
was stripped out of um why didn't the
president mention it
and is he willing to expend political
capital on this uh yes he is absolutely
i would say that
we have been working around the clock
over the last few days behind the scenes
and publicly to convey very clearly to
uh elected officials across the country
and the american people what the impacts
will be um so i would expect you'll hear
from him uh more soon about it and um on
on the meeting that jake sullivan or the
the conversation that jake sullivan had
with the russian security council
secretary um
can you say why that particular person
was the one that the u.s reached out to
why he was the one that jake had a
conversation with is is there anything
about his proximity to putin or anything
else that we should know i don't think
there's more to detail from here
uh go ahead michael uh a couple
questions on russia uh obviously the
president calling vladimir putin
personally
are you going to be detailing
whether orders to strike maternity
awards residential buildings uh innocent
children
were coming from the very top
well i would say there's a legal process
where all of the data and information
gathered will be fed into any
international investigations that's led
by the state department i think i spoke
to this a few minutes earlier where i
conveyed the president was directly
answering a question and speaking to his
own
passion and watching the barbaric
actions of a brutal dictator invading a
foreign country but there is a legal
process that is ongoing the state
department has oversight over that and
then the chinese ambassador to the u.s
published a an offer in the washington
post
he said that threats against chinese
entities and businesses are
unacceptable and quote wielding the
baton of sanctions of chinese companies
while seeking chinese china's support
and cooperation
simply won't work and we're going to
give a response
well i would say that our i don't
believe that's what we've that's an
accurate depiction of what we've been
doing what we've been conveying is that
rhetorical support or the
clear rhetorical lack of denunciation of
what russia is doing uh flies in the
face of what china stands for including
basic principles of principles of the
u.n charter including the basic
principle of respect for sovereignty of
nations and um that's just a statement
of fact obviously our objective and what
we'll watch closely is uh and i don't
have an update on it from here is uh you
know any decision to provide additional
support to russia while they're invading
foreign country go ahead thank you uh
senator chuck grassley has put a hold on
nomination of la eddie cassidy for us
ambassadorship to india
has just spoken to his friends and the
white house has reached out to him to
lift the hole or if the white house was
considering a new name for india
in the absence of it you are somewhat of
india having impact on your bilateral
relationship well he can actually
prevent a vote from moving forward on
the floor i mean he can convey his
opposition as is the right of any
senator but mayor garcetti is out of
committee and we're hoping to see a vote
on the senate floor soon and the
president has confidence in mayor
garcetti and believes he'll be an
excellent
representative in india it is critical
of course that we have confirmed
leadership uh at all of our embassies
including india and we urge the senate
to confirm him as quickly as possible in
the middle of this war with ukraine how
are the world's largest and oldest
democrats working together to bring
peace in the future well i i would say
as you know we remain uh in touch
through a range of channels from our
national security team with leaders in
india and continue to encourage leaders
to uh work closely with us to uh to
stand up against uh president putin's
invasion of ukraine go ahead
um the wheat supplies from both russia
and ukraine have been disruptive and uh
foreign quite a bit going forward
um does the u.s see the danger as some
of you talking about about a breakdown
actually a food supplies to large parts
of the world um maybe starting with
africa
this is something we're watching um very
closely i have a little bit of
information on this so let me see if i
can find it um
let's see
and we are concerned about how the wheat
supply could impact different parts of
the world less the united states
and more other parts of the world
there are also impacts we could see in
the united states including fertilizer
and the
the production of fertilizer ukraine is
a large producer of fertilizer so there
are steps the department of agriculture
has announced and we are taking steps to
work uh to address but this is something
to go back to your original question we
are monitoring closely and we are of
course continuing to evaluate what types
of humanitarian assistance we can
provide to address just a quick one on
another part of the world um
taiwan's foreign minister said just this
week might have been yesterday that the
u.s is about to announce more armed
sales to taiwan do you have anything on
that i don't have anything to predict
confirm or read out on that i'm happy to
check with our defense department go
ahead
so the president's obviously sanctioned
a lot of russian oligarchs i wonder uh
about some of the laws our laws that
enable the sort of international
kleptocracy uh obviously the president's
been outspoken about his belief that
america's tax code should be more fair
that should be enforced better and i
wonder if the president has thought
about or
has had conversations with people on the
hill about possible legislation that
would change some of these laws make
real estate transactions more
transparent require companies and trusts
to be registered to people by their
actual name
uh prevent americans from using offshore
banks as tax havens any of that under
consideration a number of those he's
expressed support for in the past i'm
happy to check with our economic team
and see if any of those are under
discussion no sense that those talks
have picked up i just don't have an
update on it go ahead karen just to go
back to jake sullivan's call you noted
when you're first talking about it that
this is the most senior conversation
between the u.s and russia since
secretary blanken's last conversation
with lavrov so why now why today has
something changed that's given the
administration uh any reason to think
this could produce some progress a call
like this i i wouldn't uh put that much
optimism in it i would say that uh there
have been ongoing direct and indirect
conversations with the russians it's not
that it stopped at any point uh we those
have happened through our ambassador um
and it just felt uh like the appropriate
time for our national security advisor
to have a discussion and directly convey
uh that there will be additional
consequences should things proceed
including if there's a use of chemical
weapons
then yeah would there be any increasing
concerns that prompted that call today
i would say that uh you know diplomatic
conversations and talks uh there isn't
always a magic reason why they happen in
a particular moment um and this was just
felt like the appropriate time for them
for us to engage at that level go ahead
i have to wrap up in a second here but
go ahead thank you jen you put out a
list of all of the military equipment
included in that 400 million at 800
million yeah that's being provided to
ukraine among those items let me read
them to you 100
grenade launchers
5 000 rifles
1 000 pistols
400 machine guns and 400 shotguns
are you saying those items
are not offensive weapons their weapons
would help the ukrainian people fight
against an invasion by a foreign country
they can be used offensively can they
not again their weapons what i'm talking
about is weapons that can be used to
fight the answer is yes i mean although
you don't want to say it that answer to
that question is yes
and so obviously you're trying to make
this distinction between offensive well
what we're talking about let me finish
let me finish let me finish let me
finish my answer no you aren't no i was
finishing a point and then you can
respond to mine okay go ahead all right
you're making this distinction between
offensive and defensive weapons
anybody that looks at that list of
weapons that i just mentioned they would
say clearly they're offensive if a
ukrainian military
officer or someone who is enlisted has
one of these weapons they can take out a
russian military official of some sort
with these weapons they're offensive in
nature so why not provide
more offensive weapons like this to the
ukrainian military well first of all we
are providing a range of rifles etc
there is a difference between a plane
and planes and massive military systems
i think anybody would recognize this
and what we were talking about which is
giving rifles and pistols to many of
them farmers and people living in
countrysides to defend themselves i
think there's a difference that most
people recognize thank you everyone so
much have a nice day
i will get you tomorrow i'm sorry i have
to wrap up